well i'm starting today with brand new
allegations of even more criminality by
the trump crime family call them what
you want this doesn't even have to do
with anything allegedly done during the
administration this has to do with the
last couple of months yesterday
congresswoman liz cheney during another
installment of the january 6 trump riot
committee hearings announced that donald
trump has recently attempted to call a
forthcoming witness to try to intimidate
them presumably and that this has been
referred to the department of justice if
this is true and did trump leave a
voicemail we don't know the details yet
we will get to that if this is true
this is new alleged criminality so let's
go through it axios reporting liz cheney
says trump attempted to reach out to
january sixth witness
she said yesterday that former president
trump personally called an unidentified
january sixth committee witness cheney
says the committee has referred the
matter to the department of justice
which has the power to prosecute the
former president
if it determines he tampered with a
congressional witness let's take a look
at the video this is absolutely stunning
stunning stuff
and one more item after our last hearing
president trump
tried to call a witness in our
investigation
a witness you have not yet seen in these
hearings
that person declined to answer or
respond to president trump's call
and instead alerted their lawyer to the
call
their lawyer alerted us
and this committee has supplied that
information to the department of justice
let me say one more time
we will take any effort to influence
witness testimony very seriously
thank you mr chairman i yield back
so the question of course is did donald
trump leave a voicemail because
attempted to call
the target of the call
didn't take the call
if you just have a missed call it could
be argued it was someone using trump's
phone how did you know it was really
trump how did you know there was going
to be an attempt to tamper with the
witness if trump was dumb enough to
leave a voicemail and we don't know the
answer to that that becomes a very
different story now there's been a
number of you emailed me and said
is it witness tampering if they never
actually speak to the witness well with
bribery attempting a bribe even if the
bribe is rejected is still a crime
this is sort of less clear and i looked
at different legal opinions on it and
it
there are many who say it's a crime
merely to attempt the tampering the
question is
how can you prove there was an attempt
we just don't know whether there's a
voicemail or not now this would be
shocking
if it weren't so predictable and it's
important to restate that this is also a
witness that has not been part of the
hearings yet this is presumably a
forthcoming witness and for trump to
personally call them suggested someone
very very close to trump now speculation
is could it be one of his own kids in
which case well we pro i mean i don't
know maybe he's maybe he doesn't speak
to his kids very often but maybe he does
uh jason campbell on twitter
called the waning weeks of the trump
administration
a shockingly incompetent empire of
criminality and if indeed the allegation
here is true that trump personally
called to try to tamper with the witness
and by tamper we mean influence the
testimony of that's really what we're
talking about the sort of mob boss
tactics of listen uh i know that you're
going to
do the right thing
and remain loyal because you're just
that type of person right this is these
are the mafia tactics that liz cheney
has previously said have been part of
the mo
of the former trump administration
during the january six committee
hearings and then the the last thing is
and of course we people are innocent
until proven guilty there's no question
of that in the legal system people are
innocent until proven guilty but in the
court of public opinion this program
operates in the court of public opinion
not in the in a legal court
it is not the behavior of innocent
people
and people with a free clear and
innocent mind
to call witnesses to try to influence
their testimony if you believe
if you know you did nothing wrong
then you don't really have anything to
worry about now you can say well maybe
you're worried that the witness will lie
and incriminate you well that would be
perjury that would be a crime
so um
stunning
shocking in a sense but altogether very
predictable another incredible moment
during yesterday's committee hearings
the january 6 trump riot committee
hearing was when a rioter showed up
said he regrets everything and explains
that he was duped by trump we're going
to be looking at video here of of uh
january sixth writer stephen ayers who
testified to the january 6 committee
under oath
and one of the fascinating parts of this
is we've had this vague question
were the rioters really paying attention
to what trump said so the the defense
that's often made is listen a lot of
these people
they came from far away to washington dc
it couldn't possibly have been what
trump said at noon
that made them go and riot at 1pm and of
course this is a very short-sighted
analysis it's barely an analysis because
the um the the sort of incitement to
that event started well before january 6
but we're actually going to hear from
ryder himself stephen ayers tells us
during his testimony
yeah you know if trump earlier had said
go home we would have gone home we
thought that's what he wanted us to do
so let's go to the first clip uh how did
he end up there and does he still
believe the election was stolen because
remember the the reason for the rioting
was the election was stolen by joe biden
and we've got to take it back stephen
ayers was asked about this interesting
answer you know that's basically what
got me to come down here
and do you still believe the election
was stolen
not so much now um
i got away from all the social media
when january 6 happened
uh basically deleted it all
you know i started doing my own research
and everything and
for me for me
for something i mean his own research
got him into this problem in the first
place but okay it's still interesting to
listen to it to be that
actually for that to actually take place
it'd be it's too big you know there'd be
there's no way to keep something like
that quiet
as big as something like that
you know
with all the you know all the lawsuits
being shot down one after another that
that was mainly what convinced me
so
this is someone who either has been
coached or is willing to see reason i
mean everything he's saying is
completely true the problem is we knew
all of this on january 5th of 2021
60 lawsuits went nowhere that
information was available on january 5th
before anyone decided to show up before
anyone actually showed up and write it
maybe they had decided already the fact
that such a conspiracy would require so
many moving parts and so many people to
be involved it was election officials
and uh precinct monitors and state
officials and federal people
coordinating and the people controlling
the machines we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines yeah that
analysis was available to stephen ayers
on january 5th so listen this guy
is in trouble he potentially has been
coached but it's still interesting to
hear what he had to say now later ayers
testified that when trump said on
twitter it's time for you to go
they decided to go they were as far as
they believed doing whatever trump
wanted them to do tweet i believe that
included a video telling people to go
home um did you see that and did that
have any effect on what you were doing
when we were there
as soon as that come out everybody
started talking about it and that's it
seemed like it started to disperse
you know some of the crowd obviously
you know once we got back to the hotel
room we seen that it was still going on
but it definitely dispersed a lot of the
crowd and did you leave at that point
yeah we did yeah we left
so in other words that was the key
moment when you decided to leave when
president trump told people to go home
yeah yep we left right when that come
out
so
very clear
they were there because of trump and
when trump said go home they left very
hard to argue that trump had nothing to
do with this
um he actually said stephen ayers did
later in his testimony
if trump had tweeted to leave earlier
they wouldn't even have been there in
the first place
um yeah i think everybody thought he was
going to be coming down um
you know he said in his speech
you know kind of like he's going to be
there with us
wow i mean i think i believed it yeah i
understand
um
we know that you illegally entered the
capitol that afternoon and then left the
capitol area later on what what made you
decide to leave
um basically when president trump put
his tweet out we literally
left right after that come out um
you know
to me if he would have done that earlier
in the day
1 30 i i you know
you know we wouldn't be in this
maybe wouldn't be in this bad of a
situation or something whatever you
think about stephen ayers whatever his
intentions are now and listen i'm right
there with you this guy has every he's
going to tell us in a moment in the next
clip his life is ruined he lost his job
he had to sell his house
he has an interest in portraying himself
as the reformed clear thinking former
trump guy who denounces everything
no question about it
it's abundantly clear
that they were paying attention to what
they believed donald trump wanted trump
made it seem like he was going to march
with them down to the capitals even
ayers testified to that as well all
right last clip here
ayers says this has ruined his life and
that makes sense do we feel bad well you
tell me i mean
if you believe in personal
responsibility he made these decisions
looking back on it now how do you
reflect on the role that you played in
the crowd that day and what is going on
in your life um
basically you know i lost my job
um
since
this all happened you know uh
pretty much sold my house
so
everything that happened with the
charges you know thank god uh
a lot of them did get dismissed because
i was just holding my phone but at the
same time i was there
so i mean it definitely it changed my
life you know uh and not for the good
definitely not for the you know for the
better
um
yeah i mean
so whatever your thought is on how
honest stephen ayers was in the
testimony or whatever else
the important things here are number one
these people were genuinely duped by
trump and the people around him now we
can say we don't care we can say they
deserved it we can say that it was their
responsibility these are adults i'm with
you
but they were duped by trump and so the
idea that trump was an irrelevant player
here absolutely untrue secondly
the idea that had trump called them off
earlier they would have left at least
steven ayers is saying of course we were
we were following what we understood
to be donald trump's direction and that
is another key component here so a
fascinating day and it is expected that
next week there's going to be another
blockbuster day of testimony uh which we
will of course be covering for you on
the podcast and potentially live as well
let me know your thoughts about steven
ayers as a witness smart to bring him
not smart did we learn anything or not i
think it was an absolutely great
decision
some people emailed me said i didn't get
the point of this testimony oh i got the
point the point was was very clear
and uh i think it was a good decision
let me know you can find me on twitter
at dpakman we'll take a quick break and
be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is an audience
supported podcast youtube channel radio
show and tv show you can sign up at
joinpackman.com you'll get the daily
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show and
so many other great things you can sign
up at joinpacman.com and the coupon code
available if you'd like it is big voting
22 saves you
saves you a lot i think it's more than
50 or 60 it's a good deal
joinedpakman.com is the place to do it
one of the questions that we've been
asking and that has been increasingly
answered has been
who knew and how widespread was the
foreknowledge that regardless of the
2020 election results failed former
president donald trump was going to
declare victory well over time we've
learned that more and more people were
aware that this was donald trump's plan
regardless of the outcome we've heard
now that a a drunken rudy jew allegedly
drunk drunken rudy giuliani
was suggesting that he do it on election
night but even earlier than that in late
october we now have leaked audio a
former trump adviser and propagandist
stephen bannon saying the plan is to say
that he won he might not have won but
the plan is to say that he won and this
is an explosive new report from mother
jones leaked audio before election day
bannon said trump planned to falsely
claim victory
bannon who at that point was no longer
officially working for trump knew the
plan if bannon knew it how many people
working for trump knew it it's very
clear that this was
obviously the plan that they had
that's our strategy he's going to
declare himself a winner we actually
have the leaked audio
let's take a look at it
the democrats
more of our people vote
early that count theirs voted mail and
so they're going to have a natural
disadvantage and trump's going to take
advantage of that that's our strategy
this is a declaration of winner so when
you wake up wednesday morning
it's going to be a firestorm now
they had the same information we had
back in what
july august september of 2020
i was telling you i was telling
everybody there's going to be this red
mirage
we expect that
for a number of different reasons
including that democrats seem more
poised and more likely to vote by mail
that the early results may favor trump
more than the eventual results
and that over the course of the evening
and depending on which state because
some states stop counting at 10 pm or 11
pm and then start up again the next day
over the course of the night or the next
day
joe biden was going to gain momentum
we knew that they knew that as well
bannon admits it here he says there's
going to be the situation where our the
the voting trends are going to favor
trump early so trump's just going to go
out there and declare victory let's
listen to a little bit of that um
again because it's so critical and then
we'll keep going
early they count theirs voted mail and
so they're going to have a natural
disadvantage and trump's going to take
advantage of that's our strategy he's
going to clear himself a winner so when
you wake up wednesday morning
it's going to be a
you're going to have antifa crazy the
media crazy no antifa did and diva did
nothing and antifa was a non-factor he's
wrong about that
courts are crazy and trump's going to be
sitting there mocking tweeting you lose
i'm the winner i'm the king
and he'll be all over hillary he'll be
going where's hunters hunter on a crack
pipe i mean no he'll be because then it
doesn't matter remember
here's the thing after then trump never
has to go to a voter again
he's going to fire ray the fbi director
father seems to say [ __ ] you how about
that because he's never going to he's
he's done his last election oh he's
going to be off the chase
also if trump is if trump is losing
by 10 or 11 o'clock at night it's going
to be even crazier
no because he's going to sit right there
and say they stole it
and that's exactly what he did yeah
i'm directing the attorney general
to shut down all ballot places in all 50
states it's going to be enough he's not
going out easy if biden's winning
trump is going to do some crazy
and that is exactly what happened so
this is a leak the leak is relevant why
because it tells us that even people no
longer in trump's inner circle knew what
the plan was bannon was not working for
trump at that point and he knew exactly
what the plan was and he was right
that's from that's from the end of
october 2020 and that's exactly what
happened so it is a leak but from what
donald trump said publicly it was clear
since the summer of 2020 that he was
going to claim to be the winner one way
or another he was saying oh the this
vote by mail stuff is all fraud i mean
trump voted by mail sure but that's
trump other people are committing fraud
by voting by mail democrats black people
others
so it was abundantly clear that this was
the plan
and bannon knew it and so the concerted
effort to carry this out as the strategy
was not a particularly closely held
secret bannon had of course more
specific knowledge bannon knew oh well
he's going to try to shut down ballots
trump tried to cease voting machines and
do all these different things but even
from what trump said publicly and even
from when trump was asked will you
accept the results if they say that
biden won and he said well i'd have to
see what what went on first this was
actually you know what's even more
interesting is
this was the plan for the 2016 election
as well in 2016
trump thought he was going to lose to
hillary
and he was going to say oh she won
because of fraud and whatever but
trump's going to move on with his life
and go back to being businessman trump
in fact if you really want to be
historically accurate trump started with
some of the election can't be trusted
stuff in 2012
claiming that barack obama's victory
over mitt romney was you know the there
were problems with the electoral college
and all sorts of different things trump
wasn't personally involved then in 20
remember in 2016 when trump won in the
electoral college but lost the popular
vote he continues to say to this day
that he actually defeated hillary
clinton in the popular vote as well and
remember the claims of there were people
from massachusetts brought in buses to
new hampshire to help her
how people from massachusetts would be
registered to vote in new hampshire
continues to be beyond me it's never
been answered but trump still hasn't
admitted that the popular vote results
of 2016 were accurate so trump was going
to do this in 2016 he just so happened
to win electorally and then of course he
did it in 2020 and he told us that he
was going to do it so
stunning stuff that it seems everybody
knew that this was the plan and now we
have steve bannon
on the record due to this leak saying
this was the plan all along
not a particularly good week for
republican senator lindsey graham a
judge has ordered lindsey graham to
testify
in the georgia trump fraud case now the
back story on this is that in the state
of georgia trump wanted trump demanded
11
780 votes he called brad raffensberger
and others in georgia and in the midst
of this lindsey graham also made a phone
call lindsey graham is a sort of
i guess in a sense i would call him a
fair weather trump supporter when things
are going well for trump he supports
trump but then on the night of january
6th he said it's over it's time to move
on okay
he lindsey graham was subpoenaed in the
georgia
grand jury investigation of trump's
attempt to overturn to steal let's call
it what it is to steal the georgia
electoral votes lindsey graham upon
receiving the subpoena said i'm going to
fight this subpoena his lawyers used all
sorts of different arguments and a judge
has said no
you've got to show up let's take a look
at this nbc news report a judge ordered
senator lindsey graham to testify
in front of a special grand jury in
georgia investigating former president
donald trump's alleged attempts to
overturn the results of the 2020
election fulton county superior court
judge robert mcburney ordered that
graham will be required to testify
august 2nd the judge's certification
filed monday describes graham as a
necessary and material witness to the
grand jury probe the development was
reported earlier by wsb tv
graham's office did not immediately
respond to requests for comment the
senator's attorney said last week he
would not comply
the grand jury also subpoenaed members
of trump's former legal team including
personal lawyer rudy giuliani now one of
the arguments that lindsay's lawyers
made in this entire thing
is that his actions in calling georgia
officials to ask what's going on can we
get the right count whatever he was
doing
the argument his lawyers made was that
lindsay's actions are protected under
these constitutional safeguards for
members of congress not getting punished
for their speech or actions performed in
the course of their legislative duties
so to explain that in layman's terms
the lawyers for lindsay said when
lindsay called
to inquire about those election results
he was performing legislative duties as
a senator of the united states
that probably sounds like bs to you and
it is and both the d.a and the judge
said
graham isn't a georgia resident and
graham is not a georgia
and u.s senators don't have any
legitimate congressional function in
personally calling state election
officials to argue about the results or
to suggest that the results might be
wrong it's it doesn't make any sense
it's not an art but as a senator he has
no role there he has no standing he's
not a voter so he can't use that
argument what he was doing was he was
trying to trade on his name and
influence by calling and saying hey this
is lindsey grim i'm a u.s senator i'm
paying attention to what you're doing
don't you think maybe you could review
the results and maybe see if they
weren't right but there was no
legitimate legislative function as a u.s
senator being served there and
unfortunately the judge agreed with that
you don't get to choose which laws you
would like to follow
i mean sometimes these people in power
do but you shouldn't get to anyway and
lindsey graham at least for now and
we'll see if he
appeals the decision if it's subject to
appeal or what he tries to do between
now and august 2nd in principle he is
supposed to show up and testify on
august 2nd i know that clearly his
lawyers don't want him to that's why
they tried every possible argument to
get him out of it and if indeed he does
testify it should be absolutely
fascinating we will have the clips and
more of the stories that we talked about
in this segment on the david pakman show
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show also follow me on instagram
at david.pacman
the uh the hate voicemail i posted
yesterday
incredible reaction i think close to a
thousand comments on it listen to it on
my instagram david.pakman let me know
what you make of it
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show today we're going to
be speaking with anthony barnett who's a
founder of the london based global
website open democracy and has also just
published taking control humanity and
america after trump and the pandemic uh
anthony really great to have you on
very good to be with you david so i mean
tell us what what's the main premise
what's the big change that you're
looking at now in this post-trump at
least for now
and maybe getting to post-pandemic
although not really and it's sort of a
question mark but at least out of the
initial stages of it what what is
materially changed in your mind yeah
well you're right to say post trump
right for now because i found two things
really surprising about what happened
uh uh when i asked when i was watching
the january 6th event and afterwards
because when it happened i thought trump
is finished
and the first shock was the way in which
the republican party rallied to his
support
and i think what this means is that if
he comes back
or if a trump-like supporter right to
sanchez comes back
it will be the closest thing to fascism
that i have ever expected in my lifetime
what i call modern factions it won't be
nazis it might be expansionist
but they their calling card is now to
break the rules to break the sense of
consent and in effect implement a form
of white supremacy this is really
dangerous not just for for america but
for all of us around the world so that
was my first shock and the second one
was a different kind of surprise which
was when
biden became president and he thanked
explicitly bernie sanders and the bernie
sanders movement and he reached out to
progressives in a constructive fashion
and that proved very popular and in
terms of my lifetime i've lived under
since you know the beginning i mean i
remember reagan and thatcher and since
the beginning of what you might call
some money monetary monetism that that
sense that the government is the problem
and the market knows the solution
progressives like myself have been
pushed to the margins there's been it's
been a
sense of saying you've you know you've
got to accept the market there was a
propagation of what i call fatalism in
the book and oddly enough trump broke
fatalism he made voting count he
empowered his followers
and at the beginning of the biden
presidency there was a sense of
an intelligent empowerment taking place
as a counterweight and i thought that
that is historic what you're doing in
america the potential i know everybody
in america at the moment all progressing
them are feeling very down there's the
supreme court decisions are making it
even worse there's a sense of pessimism
in the air
but the thing is biden won with a seven
million plurality
trump got the largest vote any sitting
president ever got in history got four
and a half million more votes than obama
did and obama got
69.5 million the largest ever trump got
74 million and then got 81 million
so we if i can put it like that we
progressives are the majority we've got
to get our act together the system is
rigged against us
and and so i felt we had to address this
and the question i asked myself
is what given the defeat of the left
given the defeat of progressives
given the defeating effect of the
socialist argument of the trade union
movement
why are progressives so strong
how come there was a seven million
majority
what is the strength i can understand
the weaknesses and then i look to this
question of what i call the humanization
it's feminism black lives matter human
rights underneath marketization
all these forces against the market were
growing and i think that
from the point of view whether it's
putin or whether it's trump uh that's
the or she in china or modi in india
that's their threat they're there they
understand the threat of real democracy
uh in a way that the
i think that the leadership of the
progressive movement certainly leads to
biden leadership doesn't fully
understand also is rather frightened of
and we've got to get our act together
and that's what i've been trying to
explore and that's why i'm very pleased
to be on your program i want to talk i
think there's a bigger conversation a
worldwide conversation is needed to sort
out how we go from here well it's
interesting when you talk about the um
olive branches extended by joe biden to
progressives you know what i think my
audience which is mostly progressive um
did not feel as though there were really
too many olive branches i mean i'll give
i'll give you my perspective at the time
which was yes i voted for joe biden i
believed that on paper joe biden ran on
the most progressive platform of any
democratic nominee i mean if you look at
obama in 2012 there and hillary in 2016.
on paper for what joe biden was
promising it was to the left of that to
some degree but also there was this
feeling that he his heart really wasn't
in a lot of the things he was sort of
agreeing to like for example
joe biden talked about maybe some
student loan forgiveness i didn't
believe for a second that that was
really something biden was interested in
and he's really not done anything on it
cannabis decriminalization or
legalization he sort of paid a little
bit of lip service to it
i didn't think he really cared about
that and he's not really taking any
action on it other than i think about a
hundred people
whose records have been expunged for for
cannabis related crimes or something
like that so i went in there with eyes
wide open
knowing that this was the better option
i voted for him i think he's done some
good things but at the same time i i
don't know that the majority of my
progressive audience feels as though the
olive branches were serious or that
they've been followed through on
yeah well i think this is this is right
but i think that so there's different
things here there's biden himself i
think the mind himself
was actually shocked by
trump's uh willingness to reach out to
fascists and i don't think biden is a
racist i think that's really important
and i think that his he genuinely was
pleased to put a black woman in the
supreme court i think that he does
believe in in integration he is he's a
multi-racial figure i mean that's a very
deep and a very important issue and i
think that he reached out with
his heart wasn't in it but the point was
and what he stated and he understood is
that without the support of the
transformative promise
of the of the bernie sanders movement he
wouldn't have won
so is that i guess progress even if it
was cynical it's still point of view of
from our point of view we've got to say
okay okay right we've got something
going for us here right of course we're
not looking biden is a creature of the
american political establishment
of the last 40 years he pre-dates
neoliberalism he predates the
marketization but um and we've there's
got to be a big generational change
taking place so so okay we've got some
strength here and how do we build on
this strength and i think one of our
problems has been one of the problems in
america but it's also a problem here in
the uk is too much looking at the
president at the center you know the the
right built its strength on the in the
states it built its strength locally
so it's building locally as well
we've got to be able to del there are
there's a very big progressive caucus in
the in the congress and i made a short
film called u.s progresses on the knife
edge i went to washington to investigate
the argument of my book to test it if
you like i talked to
a representative jamie raskin i talked
to pramila jayapal who's the chair of
the congressional
progressive caucus and i talked to
representative ro kahana who represents
silicon valley from california and they
were very interesting and articulate and
suit and reaching out it seemed to me
these are not kind of you know um that
they're seeking to gain popular support
but there isn't a progressive gathering
of governors of the us states
there's a weakness our weakness isn't
just oh well look biden isn't delivering
for us it's we've got to think okay this
is really serious we're up against
fighting we're not going to stop this
guy
and and those forces we've got to build
the alternative in a way that's credible
and build on that majority in terms of
building and alliances you you talk
about
the need for the progressive left to
ally with centrists to achieve
substantive
progress in in some senses and i think
the question of alliances is an
interesting one it's also very different
depending on whether a country has a
parliamentary system with proportional
representation or a system like the
united states or whatever the case may
be when it comes to
or i guess even thinking about it more
broadly
if the centrists
don't really want the things the
progressives want who's compromising in
those alliances
yeah well this is a very good question
uh
one thing which i think is shifting is
that
they are beginning to understand that
without being in alliance with
progressives the center is going to lose
that's a very big shift
up until now whether it was under blair
or clinton or bill clinton or even obama
they felt they didn't need they felt
they didn't need the left they all they
needed was corporate power and corporate
support and corporate competence and
that would be enough and they could
they could
rely upon the quiescence
of the population trump has made voting
count he's empowered his supporters and
unless
the the forces the democratic forces
that are opposed to trump unless we
empower our supporters we're finished
and that empowerment if you take the the
supreme court decision right on row
now what does a woman right to choose
mean in my view a woman's right to
choose is
their right to life
i think life is about choice i think one
of the extraordinary things about that
larger feminist movement is that it
empowers all of us i think men included
in
in in in greater control over our lives
and one of the great historic problems
of the center and the liberals that you
talk to is they just say we'll give you
a bit of welfare we'll give you some
maybe we'll give you students though
maybe we won't but whatever it is you've
got to be passive
they rely upon our passivity and i think
that trump has shown that that game is
over so we need to build on that and i i
think that we've got to be thinking
afresh but my argument is not that i'm
an optimist
it's that we haven't lost yet and we
need to think about what the forces the
positive forces that there are and i
think that this sense of saying okay
we're going to show you what democratic
empowerment is really about
we uh in in the few minutes we have left
i want to talk a little bit about the
next two to four years you know in uh
many in the media always like to say
this is the most interesting important
and significant election of our time
because it benefits the media because
that sounds interesting but in i've used
this example before in 2012 in the
united states when mitt romney was
challenging barack obama's re-election
i i voted for barack obama i thought he
was the better choice but it didn't feel
like it was the most consequential
election of our time it was sort of like
yes taxes on the rich will go down a
little bit if mitt romney wins and he's
socially conservative and i'm not but it
didn't feel as though there was as much
riding on it we now have a situation
where boris johnson resigning in the uk
the rise of the right-wing nationalist
parties in europe we have now in 2022
here in the united states the first
trump-era election where trump is not
president nor on the ballot and there's
this real question as to whether his
constituents will remain engaged in
politics or not and how that will relate
to 2024. i'm increasingly getting the
sense that the next election cycle or
two
in europe and the united states is
actually of major consequence in setting
the direction for the next decade or
more do you agree with that yeah i agree
with that completely this is the point i
was trying to make earlier i think that
trump now represents
a break from traditional republicanism
and there's that january the sixth
demonstrated that the fact that they're
saying the election was stolen what does
this mean
they don't there's not really a denial
that there was a seven million plurality
for biden what they're really saying is
the people who are voting
we don't count as americans
what they're saying
it's an argument for white supremacy
it's not put in ex
explicitly racist terms but that's what
it's about it's about imposing minority
rule an imposing minority rule is a kind
of fascism it's an autocracy
and that's what's at stake now
what is the opposite of that and this is
the what's exciting if you like and grim
and interesting and as you say historic
is that we can't go back
to clintonism we can't go back to obama
those days are over partly because of
the financial crisis no everybody knows
that government is not the problem we
can't trust the market so so we've got
to
a choice is beginning to face historic
choices being forced on the united
states
either
trumpism or a multi-explicitly
multiracial democratic future and that
means mobilizing and that means that
without progressives
the liberal center will lose
uh do you think that um at this point
what happens in the u.s
is as influential on what happens in
europe and vice versa as at prior times
has the
uh linkage been softened or made more
explicit
well that's also a very interesting
question so american hegemony over
europe has lessened american hegemony in
the world america is still the
the strongest and most powerful country
in the world militarily and economically
the dollar is still supreme but it no
longer rules the world in the way it did
that's primarily thanks to china
and that's a good thing in my view so in
one sense europe is now more important
than it was but if america goes fascist
if america embraces trump or desantis
and goes for minority rule and allies in
effect with a putin with xi and china uh
with the auth
against the european union
then uh the effect will be devastating
so this historic turning point of this
coming cycle between now and 2024
is absolutely crucial for all of us
around the world united states is still
the hinge country and the choice you're
facing is still a choice that will
affect the entire world and the future
of the planet
uh those are those are sizable stakes
that's that's for sure we've been
speaking with anthony barnett who has
just published taking control humanity
and america after trump and the pandemic
anthony really a pleasure speaking with
you today really a pleasure thank you
very much david take care
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
many of you expressed a great interest
and and enjoyment from what's going on
between elon musk and the maga people
and donald trump and there's another
crazy layer to this story which is that
donald trump spent the afternoon
yesterday on truth social also known as
truth central to donald trump attacking
elon musk and this is one of the
funniest
uh
it's sort of like a like a relationship
gone bad they're now estranged lovers of
sorts so let me give you the backstory
on what's going on
when elon musk announced he's going to
buy twitter and he's going to bring back
free speech or whatever nonsense elon
musk said
the right and the mega right flocked
back to twitter and they flock to elon
musk as their savior he's going to
return our voice and we're no longer
going to be discriminated against for
being
a transphobic or what you know whatever
they wanted to do
then
elon musk
was even further ingratiated with these
right-wingers when he started saying i
am now although i've never voted for
republicans before
i'm going to start voting for
republicans i am now going i'm still a
moderate but i'm going to start voting
for republicans because i believe
they're better than democrats and what
they offer and the maga crowd absolutely
loved it
but then
things went sour
and the first thing that happened is
that elon musk said i'm actually not
going to buy twitter and over the
weekend during his anchorage alaska
rally donald trump uh said elon musk
told me that he voted for me but then
later he said i've never voted for
republicans before elon musk reported
responded to that report on twitter and
said not true
saying trump is lying saying i never
told donald trump that i told him that i
voted for him and then at the very same
anchorage
rally
donald trump started uh going after elon
musk in a more significant way another
one of our highest priorities under a
republican congress will be to stop
left-wing censorship and to restore free
speech in america
and go out by the way while i'm here and
sign up now for truth social it's hot as
a pistol and you see that i pull that
one right
leon
i tell you what
elon
elon
is not gonna buy twitter
where did you hear that before
from me
from a fake account she says fake a lot
of them
nah he's got himself a mess you know he
said the other day oh i've never voted
for a republican i said i didn't know
that he told me he voted for me
so he's another [ __ ] artist but he's
not going to be buying it
he's not going to be buying it
although he might later huda hell knows
what's going to happen he's got a pretty
rotten contract i looked at his contract
not a good contract yeah unclear how
trump got a hold of that contract but
anyway so elon musk responded to that as
well and he said listen uh this is a
quote from elon musk i don't hate the
man but it's time for trump to hang up
his hat and sail into the sunset
democrats should also call off the
attack don't make it so that trump's
only way to survive is to regain the
presidency so musk turning on trump the
mega twitter people going bonkers and
then trump just absolutely erupts
yesterday on truth social spending the
afternoon ranting and raving about elon
musk saying quote when elon musk came to
the white house asking me her for help
on all of his many subsidized projects
whether it's electric cars that don't
drive long enough by the way
i mean you know
praise or criticize musk for whatever
you want but the range on tesla's is at
the top of electric vehicles okay
electric cars that don't drive long
enough driverless cars that crash or
rocket ships to nowhere without which
subsidies he'd be worthless and telling
me how he was a big trump fan and
republican i could have said drop to
your knees and beg and he would have
done it
now elon should focus on getting himself
out of the twitter mess because he could
owe 44 billion dollars for something
that's perhaps worthless also
lots of competition for electric cars ps
why was elon allowed to break the 15
million dollar stock purchase barrier on
twitter without any reporting that is a
very serious breach have fun elon and
jack
go to it now funny that trump tags
jack dorsey
but that's jack dorsey's on twitter he's
not on truth social as far as i could
tell
look at how quickly elon musk went from
right wing savior to right wing enemy
just because he said i'm not buying
twitter
i never told trump i voted for him and
trump should move on from politics and
he is now the enemy
this is the epitome of how trump works
but it is also
how the maga people work
you're either uniquely good or uniquely
bad you're either the absolute best
person in the world or someone who
should be ostracized and maybe even
imprisoned if donald trump really
doesn't like you and all along whatever
your opinion is of elon musk
elon musk's behavior was his typical
sort of self-centered
um uh what whatever it was i called it
yesterday it's sort of sort of like a
self-centered uh prioritization of his
own interests at the end of the day
and we've seen this with trump before
and we've seen this with the trump
people oh this this person is now bad
he's on some kind of naughty list and it
is absolutely childish it's
extraordinarily pathetic and by the way
for someone who said i'm going to be a
great president because i'm going to
pick the right people to work with
it's incredible how poor trump's
judgment has been selecting all sorts of
people for his staff who he ultimately
has to fire or demand resignations from
and then says they were terrible people
all along they were incompetent they
were given too much of responsibility
well who gave them that responsibility
it was donald trump none of musk's views
have changed whatever they are and
whatever you believe them to be they
haven't changed what's changed is that
donald trump started making specific
claims about things elon musk told him
and musk says i didn't say those things
and now trump ends up like a little kid
spending his afternoon on truth social
attacking elon musk stunning stunning
stuff and humiliating
let's talk about ron desantis let's talk
about the 2024 primary
the biggest signal yet
that ron desantis plans to run for
president in 2024
regardless of whether trump is a
candidate is that desantis is now
holding
uh fundraisers with republican mega
donors and it's very clear what the plan
is here
i mentioned this yesterday and i said we
would delve into it more deeply today
if the republican mega donors say to
desantis
if you run in 24
we will support you rather than trump
that gives desantis the confidence to go
up against trump in a contested primary
one of the things that has infuriated
trump about desantis is that over the
last year when asked
would you only run
if trump doesn't
will you rule out a run if trump does
want the nomination desantis has
declined to make that promise he's just
said i just haven't made a decision yet
i haven't decided yet
and now desantis
is doing a major fundraiser cnbc
reporting florida governor ron desantis
plans utah fundraiser with republican
mega donors signaling possible
presidential run yeah you you do that if
you're thinking of running for president
florida governor ron desantis is
planning a private fundraiser in utah
with some of the country's wealthiest
republican donors desantis hasn't
publicly ruled out a run for president
in 24 even if it means challenging trump
desantis spokeswoman lindsey kernut
wouldn't confirm
any details saying the campaign doesn't
discuss private fundraising events with
members of the press
this is going to be uh next week the
week of july 18th
many of the attendees asked not to be
identified because the campaign is
trying to keep the private event from
getting too much public attention
desantis is coming to utah to raise
money for his 2022 gubernatorial
re-election campaign fundraisers in
far-flung states like utah more than 2
000 miles from florida where desantis is
actually a candidate right now often
suggests
national aspirations so the next
question is what does the polling look
like desantis hasn't said he's running
and trump hasn't said that he's running
well we have recent data um polling
republican primary polling and it sort
of looks okay for ron desantis
considering he hasn't announced anything
yet uh polls uh okay morning consult
from a few days ago trump 52 desantis
21. now understand
trump's up 30.
desantis
is not a former president desantis is
not nearly as well known as trump not
even not even marginally as well known
as trump uh and desantis hasn't
announced anything and he's already
polling 21
uh from a few days prior new york times
siena college poll has desantis with 25
again trump plus 24.
a few days earlier the courageous
conservatives pack poll
has a lot of undecideds and and other
candidates but has trump 38 to santa 17
that's only a 21 point margin for
desantis and then um a poll at the end
of june as well from harvard university
harris um
desantis uh doing significantly better
than pence despite pence being the
former
of vice president so that's interesting
the polling numbers don't look bad for
desantis despite desantis having taken
no moves yet and then maybe more
importantly at this early stage when you
allow people to bet money on who they
believe will be the nominee sometimes
you get
more forward-looking data or information
and if you look at the
betting markets right now
there is only a seven cent difference
and i'll explain what that means between
donald trump and ron desantis this is
not who will you support
this is bet money
who will win the 2024 republican
presidential nomination
um when it comes to trump you have to
bet 42 cents to make a dollar
and when it comes to ron desantis you
have to bet 35 cents to make a dollar
that means it is seen as only slightly
less likely
that desantis will be the nominee than
trump those are incredible numbers this
far out particularly considering that
desantis hasn't announced anything now
trump hasn't either but as i said trump
is much more well known and donald trump
also um uh
is
talking about running in a way that that
ron desantis isn't also relevant nobody
else is even in the picture i mean
you've got nikki haley pence glenn
younkin mike pompeo ted cruz tim scott
just pennies pennies pennies on the
dollar so the truth is if desantis wants
this it's not a guarantee that he could
win but he will be a player for sure and
if he gets that republican mega donor
support if the republican mega donors
kind of you know give him the old wink
wink and say
if you were to run
we would be eager to support an
alternative to what we've done in the
past i think desantis is very very well
positioned we have a voicemail number
that number is 2192 david p
here's a question from a viewer is
merrick garland may be just waiting to
indict everyone all at once once the
january 6th committee hearings are over
hey david sir
this is jeremy from new jersey
uh with everything that's been going
on
with the january 6th committee yeah it
seems obvious that trump and some of his
associates
have committed treason
yet the just department justice
hasn't taken action against many of
these people
and
personally i'm hoping
that the doj is waiting to take action
at the end of the hearings
in the hopes that
public opinion
will get turned in their favor
but i'm curious what your thoughts are
on that well i have two thoughts first
of all i don't like a department of
justice that's making decisions on
charging people based on public opinion
they should be making decisions and
charging people based on the evidence
that they have so in that case i hope
that what the doj is doing is not
waiting for public opinion for charging
these co-conspirators to be higher that
would be a bad thing
the other piece of this is the truth is
it takes a while for the department of
justice to put together charges they
have to investigate they have to decide
what what are what can we prosecute what
could we get a guilty verdict on etc so
it's just as plausible
that it's not that the department of
justice is waiting it's that
as the january 6 committee exposes
possible criminality the doj starts to
investigate and it can take a few months
to put together what the charges are now
that's optimistically thinking i still
have seen no evidence that merrick
garland actually wants to or is willing
to charge anybody high level in the
trump uh uh uh administration up to and
including donald trump i've just seen no
interest from him in doing that and
we'll continue to follow it i hope that
that is not the case
but i'm not feeling particularly
optimistic about it we'll talk on the
bonus show today about the new images
from the james webb space telescope many
of you requesting the story super
interesting new york city monkey pox
cases have doubled again
not good and jill biden has now
apologized after saying that latinos are
as unique as breakfast tacos very very
weird thing to say and we will talk
about it on the bonus show get instant
access
by signing up at joinpacman.com i will
see you then
you